thinking of doing a bit about like what
if my dog had a cell phone you know like
I go to the store I come home there's
382 missed calls I want to do a bit on
leaves you know like why do they call
them leaves most of the time they're on
the tree they should be called stays
that that funny you think leaves should
be called stays right dogs dogs oh good
think about it dogs are good how's that
guy at work he works like a dog
howdy sleep last night oh he slept like
a dog is he loyal loyal as a dog oh yeah
I see where you goin Bubba but wait hold
on this more dogs are good unless you're
a girl dog then you're a even if
you're the son of a girl dog it's bad
sons of never heard about
daughters of if you're a girl
you're a if you're the daughter of
a you're fine we got nothing for
you that funny is that funny I think
that's good right yeah yeah they're sons
of but there are no donors and
benches if you're a daughter of a
you're just a wait what see what
are you doing but it's supposed to be me
dance we tellin you sound like this I
don't sound like that yogurt
well I ain't playin yo what is it
hip-hop dairy that's you I don't sound
like that
I don't selling then starving good
coming out
mommy I got a bit about money I want to
run it by you all right
everything about the names of money why
do they call money dough because you
need it oh my god that's not good now
you need the dough to make the bread
it's called oh it's called bread it's
gone Chetta
we're halfway to make it a pizza here's
the funny thing though pizza costs
nothing
Little Caesars is two dollars the dough
costs no doubt is that anything that's
funny right huh
you know it's it's good it's just a
little um it's a little white it's a
little literal well maybe it's supposed
to be Pete maybe it's wordplay you know
yeah but that's not all you do you know
it's more nuanced and crafted you're
right do you ever think about the word
diner
nobody diners are the only places that
are named after the people occupying
them okay I'm the diner and I'm in the
diner what am i doing dining exactly
they don't call a car a driver they
don't call a phone booth the caller you
don't call a head a head you don't call
your underwear genitals you have a lot
of these you don't call the fridge of
food or I think maybe you do one or two
you don't call your oven a food lot of
you don't call microwave a food you
don't call a food court a food
you don't call freezer a food get all
call supermarket a food oh is that
anything is that anything